the seal but they have created
unbearable conditions for Maria Putin
and threatened her with a long prison
sentence and they provided real examples
to her there are many of them so our
camp at RIT was made was made it admit
to all ridiculous and we will qualify
her arrest and the confinement of Maria
Putin as the political pressure
political blackmailing and she's
political prisoner for us proceed
against reboot Annette is desperation
certain political groups in the United
States to instigate the anti-russian
hysteria to find any information that
could be far-fetched and could be used
in the confirmation of the allergic
Russian meddling into American elections
will do everything to release Maria
Boonton and return her to Russia today
the Russian ambassador extraordinary
potential Andrei colorful as a result of
the terrorist attack in Ankara Turkish
law enforcement officers completed the
criminal email investigation and the
materials will be examined by Russian
investigators who are in permanent
contact with Turkish colleagues with
hope that offenders will be found and
they will be brought to justice
the Russian Foreign Ministry and the
Russian embassy I am closely follows and
controls the issue part of the
international agenda situation in Syria
with borghese new stupid pyramid visions
you can understand we're taking Stoffel
for 2018 which
serious in the station Assyrian the area
around its nature and its scale are seen
in Damascus Aleppo Homs and Latakia
it's today this city's peaceful lies
people living there don't wait for any
terrorist attacks firing they are
waiting celebrations of the new year in
the series quite a tolerant country in
everyone and got huge cheer this holiday
in Christians awaiting for Christmas but
we see that such holidays will go
unnoticed in a blip this is where a
nutri said it fighters control the
situation their administration
represented by the Salvation government
seriously make sure that any new year
symbols could be excluded from the daily
life as they think that these symbols
insult Muslims the situation is also
quite said and destroyed Raqqa there is
no one celebrate Christmas in the
discredited ruins Church it's a guest
town right now because old people
abandon the city budget the New Year's
Eve everyone takes stokehold the year a
Buddhist and everyone thinking about the
future it's a time of hope Syrians hope
additional progress is made in the
settlement process and in addressing the
crisis for the recovery of Syria Syrian
territory and elimination of terrorist
presence political social economic
reconstruction as well as astronomy for
a major staff was made the consultations
with Syria's on members of
constitutional committee
the list of members will be provided by
the foreign ministers of Russia Iran and
Turkey yesterday in Geneva they provided
this information to the UN special and
Syria Staffan de Mistura I'll remind you
that the decision on the constitutional
committee was made at the Syrian
National Dialogue Congress and so she
would hope that this crucial body will
be able to convene in Geneva and to
start its work in 2019 in order to
prepare the constitutional reform for
Syria based on region in line with the
UN Security 2254 general elections it
would be organized because we follow the
developments of stations eastern part of
Syria which witnesses increased tensions
which provoked by the montañés
illegal military presence of the United
States the fact that fashion contenders
to separatist Kurdish politicians
gravely concerned Turkey which is now
very worried very much about the
emerging threats their national security
the United States were not able to meet
their concerns and as a result of the
situation in the region along the
syria-turkey border as well as in the
areas which have experienced Isis
invasion the situation has escalated and
it risks to become an acute crisis but
the Kurdish and Syrian populations
become hostages of the situation on week
I as fighters benefit from the situation
we have also mentioned significant part
of the Syrian territory and we said that
the context of the fighting against
international terrorism the legal
American presence become an obstacle and
settlement process and our idea is
opposed it looks quite a 55 kilometers
cluesive zone organized by the United
States
in intellectual matters around illegal
military base in our tongue Americans
don't provide any access to
representative solve the Syrian
authorities and be patronized the
fighters residing in the territory and
they provide necessary training as a
result people cannot leave the territory
in an organized manner right now we are
working on the question of organizing
another Unitarian convoy through bonds
to alleviate all the burden of people
living there it's clear that and it's
evident that means to provide this
commentary and assistance however the
United States is a country occupying the
territory of where is situated should
provide all the possible insurance for
the safe passage you and I see RC and
SAARC personnel as well as well as they
need to make sure that people that need
the humanitarian assistance will receive
the furniture and assistance we also
need to make sure that this assistance
will be provided to people not to
terrorists and fighters the
investigation of the chemical incident
we see that the Technical Secretariat of
OPCW continues to delay the
investigation despite official request
of the Syrian or the Syrian side the
opcw's to investigate the use of
chemical weapons in Aleppo on the 24th
of November on the 20 on the 4th and the
6 of December Damascus was visited by
the advanced group of the special
mission they received great deal of
factual materials and they received
assurance from Syrians and Russian
military experts special missions
experts in the Aleppo will receive all
the necessary facilitation as we know
the unit apartment conceived - security
provide any recommendations against
visiting since the chemical incident but
as they say the cart remains there still
instead of too biased course making a
very practical goal which goes in line
with the mandate OPCW called it dreaming
him yes at least 90 M true mibu torchic
name is T because I stop it becomes more
difficult to get to the evidence they
bearing in mind the high volatility of
chloride which was the make shifted
chemical mo there is little chance to
detect these substances you understand
the situation shows we have provided all
the evidence best fighters recognized
but we hear statements from the gas that
the incident in Aleppo was organized by
Damascus on the chest and also Russia
was involved in the situation
again there is an urgent I need
organized probes situation at the
question took place not in distant
investigation so we have questions may
be give it away
an investigation is made to the benefit
used military force against Syria as a
member state of the union and the party
to CWC we believe that any delay in
sending experts to Aleppo goes against
the CWC
and the common sense
because civilians suffered at this
incident we turn to another situation in
the neighboring region December the
situation is escalating in on the West
Bank the Palestinian extremist attacked
three Israeli and Israeli Secret Service
soldiers killed seven Palestinians and
many people from both sides were injured
and the situation becoming even worse
due to Israel stepping up efforts to
find the perpetrators provoking mass
protests and clashes between
Palestinians and Israeli servicemen at
the same time at the excuse of a
response to the Palestinian terror the
government of Israel in violation of
resolution 23 34 of the UNSC took
additional steps to build new housing
units in Jewish settlements on the
occupied territories in particular in
the Ofra district and legalize the
existing ones them we are seriously
concerned with the new surge of violence
between the Israelis and Palestinians
and we call on and the parties to
restore the effective coordination in
the sphere of security to normalize the
situation we are certain that stepping
up illegal settlement activities won't
lead to strengthening the security of
Israel we underline that there is a need
to promote the political process between
the Palestinians and Israelis on the
basis of the corresponding decisions of
the United Nations Security Council and
the General Assembly as well as the Arab
Peace Initiative as for the voting in
the UN General Assembly on the Ukrainian
draft resolution we have already
commented on that and the comments have
been published on the official website a
Russian leadership commented on that
and now I would like to remind you that
at the 17th of December you ng a plenary
meeting Ukrainian draft resolution
called problem of the militarization of
the autonomous Republic of Crimea and
the City of Sevastopol Ukraine as well
as parts of the blackened as over was
addressed the document is politically
charged and a draws an unacceptable
accusations against Russia and is
designed the title of Ukrainian internal
political and economic issues for
Russia's mythical aggression and to prop
up the ratings of the president that has
hit record low at the same time the
draft resolution contains an
interpretation of the 25th of November
false flag operation that is distorted
by KF and doesn't conform with the
reality when three crane and warships
tried to went into the street of Kerch
with no advance notification given to
Russia papers found on board and
testimony given by the Mariners clearly
show that it was a deliberate and a
pre-planned campaign at the same time
the crane Ian provocation the Ukrainian
frame-up was carried out in violation of
the UN Charter and norms of
international law including articles 19
and 21 of the UN close that defines the
procedures and rules of innocent passage
and the right of the coastal state to
ensure security in the territorial sea
ideas about Russia's supposed
militarization of the Crimea and part of
the black sea and the seals as of
utterly untrue Russia doesn't step up
military presence in the Sea of Azov and
there are no Russian and naval bases the
forces there are used to safeguard the
crimean bridge and i will write you that
from the right from the start from the
announcement of the crimean bridge to be
built the Ukrainian leadership announced
together with
law enforcement agencies so they said
that they were going to eliminate the
bridge and the steps taken by Russia
including selective examination of ships
including Russian ships equal to the
threats posed by extremists and
including Ukrainian politicians in
relation to the Crimean bridge and
Russia Ukraine's activities that
announced the creation of a naval base
in berdyansk and that systematically
blocked several areas of the Sea of Azov
had to conduct artillery exercises in
aimed at militarization of the CF as
over unfortunately the amendments
proposed by a number of delegations to
ensure a balanced or a more balanced
reflection of the Ukrainian frame-up
couldn't correct to the
counterproductive character of the
resolution that can only damage caused
damage against this background Russia
had no other choice not to put the draft
resolution and vote and vote against it
the great number of people who abstained
from the vote the fact that the Member
States took different stances the fact
that many states didn't attend the
meeting speak volumes about their
willingness to endorse lopsided
interpretation of Kiev and we know that
many countries brazenly put pressure on
some states to vote for it despite the
fact the resolution was not supported by
the two-thirds of the UN member-states
caves counterproductive entire Russian
initiatives in the UN General Assembly
at other venues only high the internal
policy of Ukrainian leadership which
turned out to be a failure and do not
contribute to the settlement of the
internal Ukrainian crisis and
there was a question at the past
briefing we commented on that issue
bottarga turns to that topic it deals
with Nordstrom - since last week we
heard a number of remarks about that
over the past time Washington and some
European capitals once again argued
against building not stream to gas
pipeline that referring to
non-commercial character of the project
which poses a threat to the European
energy security I would like to point
out that Russia many times try to
pinpoint that such remarks to show
neither logics no common sense Europe
will buy so much gas from Russia as it
needs and there is no answer to the
question why Ukrainian monopolies of gas
transit is better than diversifying its
supply routes because there there is no
answer to this question our opponents
should have looked on the map and take
into account that over the past decade
gas has been mainly produced on the
Yamal Peninsula in the north of Russia
and the route running from that place is
2,000 kilometers shorter than streak
rain and price of gas transportation is
different especially in the Evo of
Ukraine's official announcement to raise
tariffs three times then we see the
motives of actions taken by our
colleagues from the overseas and they
try to fulfill the task over pushing
American liquefied gas into the European
market by hook or by crook just the push
the project to promote the project but
you should hold fall so on market
principles and fair competition there
Russia is ready for competition and both
on pipeline and liquefied gas and it is
not Moscow but Washington that twists
the arms of its clients and threatens
with sanctions Moscow tries at supply
gas to consumers and adequate conditions
and Washington uses direct political
pressure and when we deal with the
internal reorganization in the sphere of
commodities the production and
transportation we try to make the
product more attractive to our partners
well in this case we try to increase
competitiveness and efficiency as well
as transparency of our steps it is more
difficult to understand the logics over
several European politicians who try to
make ordinary citizens and businessmen
just pay for the recife beer and
developments in France give a clear
answer to the question where the
European consumers are ready to pay gas
bills that are higher than in Russia as
for crane we would like to know that
after four years over this I called
separation or unbundling of the
management of Ukrainian gas transmission
network we still cannot see a solid a
smart partner we are ready to negotiate
with and we are ready distill to confirm
that the concept over not stream to and
the curd Turkish stream and doesn't
imply the abandonment of the existing
gas transmission routes to Europe and it
pertains to Ukraine the transit of
Russian gas through the country can
preserved provided that the relations
between the stakeholders are settled and
the efficiency of the Ukrainian route is
confirmed them we still cannot see the
progress in this way and still Russia
agreed to continue to three party
consultation with the participation of
the EU and Ukraine on the gas transit
and it was a crane that refused to
cooperate and unfortunately there are
grounds to think that such an event will
take place in January and it will be
used by Kiev to politicize the question
and trigger anti Russian propaganda to
get schools ahead of the pre-election
period there was a question to comment
on creation of the working group in the
Council of Europe to compare the
legislation of states that take that
host 2020 we for European football
championships such group was organized
by the initiative of the Ministry of
sports in Russia in December 2016 under
the aegis of the permanent Committee of
the Commission on spectacular spectator
violence and misbehavior of the Council
of Europe the main task is to ensure
compliance with the UEFA requirements
these are so-called guarantees that
should be fixed in the national
legislation and more such requirements
with a free regime for the fans and as
we know Russia voluntarily provided many
much more guarantees than other
countries than they should according to
the UFO requirements thanks to the
successful championship in 2018 Russia
clearly demonstrated its ability to
organize major sports events ensure
security and the helpful fans feel
comfortable we believe we can share our
ideas with the working group
on the 7th of January 2019 the agreement
between the government of the Russian
Federation the government of sentiments
sent and the Grenadines on the
conditions of abandoning visa procedures
in case of travels of the citizens of
both countries entering to force it was
signed in New York on the sidelines of
the General Assembly on the 27th of
September in 2018 according to the
agreement the citizens of Russia with
valid passports that entitles them to
cross borders of foreign countries
including in diplomatic and service
passports the citizens of a sentiment
sent and the Grenadines that holders of
ordinary diplomatic and official
passports can enter exit transit and
stay on the territory over and both
countries without visas up to 90
consecutive days for a 180 day period
from the date of their first century and
the citizens of one state that intended
to stay on the territory of another
country more than a 90 consecutive days
or undertake tried to undertake
commercial or professional activities
they should get the necessary visa in
the diplomatic mission of concealer
Department in accordance with a
legislation the resi school on the 13th
of December in pretoria in the complex
of freedom there was a Solomon opening
of Russian segment about the wall of our
name so with the surnames of the 67
Soviet military specialists who was
killed during the contact in there and :
be and this event was a
reflection of a rational South African
friendship and commemoration of the
historic memory and was a symbol of a
bringing about the young generation in
this period of the posture on the
friendship in accordance with our joint
statement which were was assigned to by
mr. Putin armed force on the 26 of bomb
in July this year
and this ceremony was attended by the
ambassador of the Russian to Pretoria
mr. Petrov and by the Minister of
Culture and also for the South African
Republic mr. medve and to the minister
on small business and businesses and to
the head of the Subcommittee on
international affairs of the reporting
of the African National Congress this
was a venture attended also by the
ambassador's of a Belarus Angola
Mozambique and representative John on to
the South African Republic and their
representatives of the diplomatic corpse
to the interview regarding the decision
was taken by a Russian Federation not
conducting media material our Committee
on agreement between Russia and
Chickasaw we owe it is a special note to
the Czech Republic and this was done due
to the placement of mr. corn is
appropriate so I would like to remind
you that Russian soldiers celebrated in
Czechoslovakia and this could be proved
by special documents mr. Cornell was
awarded sure more than tea
we consult on all of the aspects of all
cooperation of a Czechoslovak and which
indicate and response so the type of a
process of by in the memory less fear we
didn't just Estrada pretentious
gastronomist ratima got any constructive
dialogue but information about Russia in
the Russian Federation so the response
will be through the interim ministerial
commission your question also to say
that on the 15th of December Russia
America the day of journalists are
killed on duty according to the UNESCO
and since this card of 2018 94
journalists were killed on duty this
statistics is complemented by an account
of the journalists that are not only
working during the conflict but also in
peaceful times for holding now the right
to get access or to adjust into a
current information and they not the
Russian Federation draws especial
attention
and for ensuring the security of
journalists and fighting the problem of
impunity against them they're monitoring
the offences against journalists and
cooperate with such international
platforms as the OSI and the UNESCO and
the situation with a security with
regarding jawless in such a state as
agreeing system of substantiated and
serious concern Russia has many times
drawn attention of international
community to the dangerous trends that
suppression of the rights of our
journalists and even to their physical
elimination and we like to point out
they and other journalists the media
representatives in agreeance have judged
to by physical violence that done on the
table for officials and the dissent of
the journalists and we call of the
International structures and agencies to
the pressure exerted on the journalists
and we assess a decision taken by the
Council of the ministers of Foreign
Affairs of the AOC as a break through
decision and defy this decision the
organization demonstration should
demonstrated a commitment to the
protection of the journalists interests
mr. Allan Roth I met at a negotiation
with a homily and said that they all
committed to the settlement of their
conflict what are the creative ideas
would be proposed by Russia in the
nagorno-karabakh settlement yes this is
these are the ideas that should be
worked on and they should be creative
and they would be supported now so the
expert on working in this area another
question the United States has confirmed
the withdrawal from the treaty from the
INF treaty and how can pressure assess
this kind of approach which is
destructive the heart could you comment
on the last statement for the United
States regarding the fears and also the
statement of mr. Mandor
regarding future provocations I haven't
seen another statement that your society
I don't know what you're speaking about
but we all wear the attitude of the
United States to the countries of the
region that you mentioned statement
attitude not as equal partners but - but
based on the meddling in other countries
appears to adjacent States under - the
state of the region this is a doesn't
apply Latin America not to come from the
sovereign states taters
but the actions of the United States
they later - quite an opposite result
this mother and that she did misery in
yeah but anyway I would have a look
after the statements regarding this
issue
but all this statements are relational
they are not constructive America song
Sputnik news agency during the press
conference if any of the as pointed work
[Music]
when one citizen of Russia were detained
in one of 17 year old historian was a
broken down and he was a team
[Music]
meaning that he had weapons you mean no
magic wand and mrs. Polanski also it was
detained because the advance of 1994 no
they believe that is the case of
espionage maybe they would discuss
further they Russia today or Sputnik
news agencies in the key in this case
how could you comment on that out
commanded as a reciprocal policy is
conducted by these countries and also
like patrol was from the line of
protecting human rights
you know these Baltic states this
politic states that were trying to
integrate the European Union and to this
European space the ideas that were
proclaimed as the main thing the main
objective projects it to the structures
this was not first parity it has nothing
to do with the development of these
states regarding the figures
for 30 years not a moment in privacy not
in protecting personal rights all these
ideas were proclaimed as a basis for the
development so the now are coming back
and maybe there's wrapping up
abandonment they establish course
establish line as for the things that
were mentioned whether there would be
some response to the crisis poor neck or
other media outlets
I think that the best the more
effectively you're working your case
would be disliked for me mr. Carson made
a statement calling Armenia to counter
the main blackmailing of the United
States is it connected somehow to the
poutine on crime here so it was made and
it was shown during the newscast and he
expressed to hold that blackmail of the
United States I think we could not even
add to this any blackmail against the
state that is difficult going through
difficult times trying to find its
yuju way of life it's an admissible
could on that maybe you should turn to
the journalist and refer to the question
asked by the journalist I don't believe
that it was a comment independent
comment of mr. kerosene just was
announced to the question the statement
17th of December made by mr. Lavrov
regarding the memoranda with Russia no
one said differently was interpreted
differently in Armenia and here maybe
you didn't see the interview there's
always didn't see any discrepancies
sounding interview from an emotional
point of view it was conducted by
Komsomolskaya journalist it was just an
interview but comments that works the
questions it was even impossible to give
correct answer because the journalists
were asking their questions at the same
time so due to this emotional nature to
the circumstances they started to talk
about the such discrepancies but
nevertheless we provided all the
transcript
specifying the names and the topics and
the terms so it doesn't really any call
to the military facilities of the
Russian Federation you should look into
the transcript and we spoke about
laboratory military laboratories cm
truly am grateful to those
representatives to those journalists of
Armenia and representatives of the media
field - who phoned me and specified what
they were talking about thank you very
much for your specification yes and I'll
repeat that I don't want to boost
someone's rankings but this interview
was particularly special in terms of
questions and wordings of questions yes
please mr. Harmon RIA Noah Steve and a
lot of you already mentioned that in the
15th of December the day of journalists
but you remember the influence and
pressure that Russian media faces in
other countries particularly in Ukraine
as for Ukrainian journalists in Russia
they have a difference the situation
they have faced no obstacles they can
visit any events so why doesn't Russia
take any retaliatory measures against
Ukrainian journalists this is the first
question at the second questions the
Secretary of the National Security
Council mr. gershenoff said that through
the Kerch Strait he's going to organize
special meeting about the situation in
the Kurdish trading and he's going to
invite partners as for the second
statement this is the another
provocative and inflammatory statement
of inflammatory nature
it's an irresponsible statement and it's
going to exacerbate the situation which
many partners of Ukraine trying I'm not
trying to de-escalate the situation and
against the backdrop of the efforts
undertaken by the EU countries such a
statement is just it's just saying that
provocation is a part and parcel of the
Kiev regime and as for your first
question I'm quite perplexed with the
question because this is the only
question that I receive I actually get
so many reproaches and letters of
criticism that the situation of Russian
journalists in Ukraine the regime for
Ukrainian journalists hasn't changed and
the regime of work for them goes in line
with the gradation rules are applied to
foreign journalists I have so many I
received so many questions about
Ukrainian journalists when Russian
journalists are even denied access to
Ukraine they said journalists who have
been doing their job quite a long period
of time they're professionals so the
questions are like why we're giving
voice to Ukrainian journalists why we're
giving them access so I faced public
criticism about that and it was said
that the Russian Foreign Ministry and I
personally intervened to
when Ukrainian journalist was detained
by law enforcement officers in Russia I
provided support and people were saying
that in this situation we had to show
the Ukrainian journalists what Russian
journalists experienced in Ukraine when
they're detained in Ukraine when they're
questioned for many hours regardless of
the fact if there are men women they
know the fact that they're professionals
I want to say the following
we shouldn't copy those who we criticize
second we act in line with the Russian
law we have an orientation rules which
argue uniformly for everyone and third
Russian journalists face so with
aggressive measures politicized
politically motivated measures that have
nothing to do with the reality they are
accused upon ridiculous charges and here
is different mechanisms we appeal to
international organizations were trying
also to address formats but if there is
no in fact we write letters to
international structures and there are
situations when we when we see that
there is a pressure
ramaya but there is also direct threats
made by Ukrainian officials against
Russian journalists when Russian
journalists are deported so when there
is a case we have to take retaliatory
measures and there are such examples so
to sum up I want to and of course I also
need to say that
we are talking about other journalists
not also Ukrainian journalists these are
journalists who are taking provocative
actions who are spreading fake news we
will provide them all the possibilities
to work on the territory of the Russian
Federation in line with the Russian law
there is a legal cultures and we are
fully committed to our obligations this
is a certain type of image that we
should pursue and support and preach any
justice whatever are the reproaches that
I received as a person responsible for
journalists in Russia I think that we
have to respect accreditation rules
which are the same for everyone the
examples that I've provided that where
the journalists face deportation and
expulsion we have to take retool tree
measures hello mr. Harbor International
Life magazine my colleagues raised the
question as the previous briefing it's
the end of 2018
many people now many people take stock
of the year and many editions choose the
question of the year so what do you
think who could be a person of the year
I cannot say personally I have no right
to make any personal remarks
the cooking here at this Tribune but I
would like to make a comment as a person
who works with information the person
who has been working in this field for
quite a long time I don't like these
nominations like person of the year
person century these are just dull names
that have no content behind them but in
the context of the security of
journalists that I was talking about
today in the context of our conversation
when we did where we discuss different
stories and situations I can say that
there were many examples actually I
would like to provide an arrow required
to a question in Syria who I would like
to talk about interesting people and
their great achievements in health care
P peacekeeping activities and further
activities today I'm talking to you as
journalists foreign and Russian
journalists and I would like to say that
for me as a person dylaney Malwa who has
made a lot and who has shown an example
that whatever are the circumstances you
will do your job and you will love your
job completion if you can go I think
that Tatiana Fillinger where is the
person showed it
she's known as person and I need to say
that we easily told about the situation
of other people and an inter say that
this person experienced so much in her
life and she found strength within
herself to continue her activities as a
journalist as if nothing changed when
you talk about her situation they maybe
have some other views about that but if
you remember what happened to her when
you experienced all this waste when you
remember that situation in the office
that happened you understand that she
truly is a Courage's and brave person
maybe we don't hold our views her views
on some situations but we see that she
showed everyone that you can experience
this horrible situation when there is a
knife at your throat but you're ready to
continue to work with her whatever the
circumstances are so in my worldview I
think she's a person who deserves the
nomination person of the year so it's
not about political that this person
decided to continue to work as a
journalist despite the fact that the
person faced the crime the attack when
she was working as a journalist this is
a great deed I think thank you very much
I was just I just wanted to ask you a
question about journalism Bernie Putin
is going to give a press conference
tomorrow all journalists are preparing a
record number of journalists was
accredited and everyone hopes that they
will be able to ask quest
every day we received thousands of
questions just imagine that tomorrow you
would be a journalist what questions
you're going to ask to Vladimir Putin I
think if I was a journalist I would be a
journalist there are no limits for me
because actually I I graduated as an
international journalist so I can we
cannot just think about it in theory
because I've made my choice already and
I'm standing in front of you right now
yes please read spring and Czech
soldiers I would like to follow up on
that with your Czech colleague said what
I've said actually in many cities of
Siberia locals do not welcome the
initiative of the Charco Defense
Ministry and they say that that that on
behalf of the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs illiterate Konev says that was
cannot desecrate burial sites of
soldiers but when the Defense Ministry
comes to Siberia and want to in store
the memorial quakes everyone is
displeased it's not about the political
influence I think that I think it's
about influence we need to provide clear
information upon the request key
decision and it's up to us so to provide
the explanations for any steps part of
the events carried out by Russia and by
the Foreign Ministry
but also music politics the Foreign
Ministry plays a coordinating role in
the Russia's foreign policy what does it
mean there is an official document that
explains the idea particular area outs
international activities Russian
structures agencies and ministries
regional constituents they coordinate
their activities with the Russian
Foreign Ministry again we're not talking
about influence we're talking about
coordination so the second question it
seems Czech Republic see sufficient in
another way maybe they are pleased with
the fact that there is no such
coordination
I think that everyone wants to benefit
from the controversial situation to make
it a big controversy we don't have any
controversy in that situation we closely
work together with activists with the
regional structures military Historical
Society we have no controversy in that
and another question the third one
actually I'm sorry about that that we
should take the so called the Syrian
situation it is said that turkey wants
to start a launcher and the attack
against Kurds and the in Syria and it
was agreed upon with trump different
dates have been mentioned
and al-nusra terrorists will soon
probably be divided from moderate
terrorists but if we watch the news we
will see that terrorist attacks go on
and turkey cannot cope with its
obligations cannot honor its obligations
but probably we should say much time has
passed and the Syrians still suffer so
this is the reason why regular meetings
with the Turkish side held different
levels at the levels available foreign
ministers with three foreign ministers
participating in it than there are
contacts with the Turkish colleagues at
the level of special representatives and
heads of states because this situation
around the Syrian settlement is not a
plan that is to be realized
it's a dynamical dynamically changing
situation many stakeholders and axes can
influence I would provide you an example
it's a situation in space it's not
simple and flat that's why it is more
difficult we should not only compare the
stances but we should sustain contacts
between diplomats and military officials
we should exchange views between
delegations of both sides to bring
together our positions when we find
common ground and at the same time try
to solve the outstanding issues in order
to come to a common denominator it's a
dynamic process and we should reckon it
too it
and why did you not sit together I am
worried about that I around
well mr. Cordova please do not frighten
me in this by miserable could you say a
few words about the frame-up related to
Sergey Lavrov it is connected with the
the Crimea well the minister you have
mentioned mr. Sergei Lavrov said that we
have the relevant information and the
idea was confirmed during the interview
with mr. Rifkin he gave the one of the
Russia's TV channels we have some
information we couldn't but share with
because this is a frame of situation
which follows the same logic the
implementation of the Minsk agreements
as we see it is impossible if cannot do
that due to internal processes despite
the fact that everyone agreed that there
is no alternative to the document at the
same time we need to solve the problems
in the region ahead of the elections
people want to see what has been done
over the years and during the last
briefing during the past breaking we
said
that such a military campaign can be the
only crazy act committed by the cave's
regime that could help certain
candidates to get scores as for the
facts I would like to refer to the
comments of Sergey Lavrov and mr. Naresh
Caen I would like to share my
impressions about the recent press
conference with father Frost and his
granddaughter that took place last year
I didn't get what you mean do you want
to be the father Frost maybe now you
have a holiday tree and father Frost and
his granddaughter well if you want it to
be the father Frost and the
granddaughter well you can dress up and
the flow is yours
well you have taken separate seats quite
early well I will think about that are
there any more questions yes please
international news agency the Bulgarian
Channel I would like to add a few words
about Sergey Lavrov comment we received
the information from the Donetsk
Republic about the provocations and
frame-up that and now the US
blames Russia namely the study boom
institute mentions that Ukraine prepares
frame of a chemical provocation against
Russia and today mr. Coad worker and
discussed the deployment of peacekeepers
in done bus does it mean that the u.s.
is preparing for a mass attack against
Russia well the role of mister could
Walker is not the role of a peacekeeper
the statements the campaign's
the official represented the US
administration is behind do not have a
peacekeeping character and unattained at
consolidating positions inside the
Ukrainian society he is not taking
efforts to realize the Minsk package of
measures the US shouldn't should have
nothing to do with that although all
constructive steps are quite welcome but
the situation is totally different
well it's the similar campaign I have
another question
today you have spoken about journalism
the colleagues have been discussing
scandal around miss yelena boyko a
ukrainian journalist the incident is
quite specific the case is difficult she
must leave Russia according to the
rulings of the
we do not know all the details but can I
have a question where the Russian
Foreign Ministry can examine the
situation in a more detailed way and let
her stay in Russia well there is a
mechanism for making such judgments and
we can voice our position in different
cases if we are requested and there have
been such cases when we were asked about
a particular journalists about his visa
accreditation but if it is a court
ruling the Minister for nafas cannot run
count it I have said today that there
are fake news there are provocative
materials that are the spontaneous or
pre-planned but the law is the law and
the accreditation rule is they credit
Asian rule it means that we should do
much to provide facts and reliable
information and as for intervention into
the work of a journalist we try to do
that only in case of Russia's
journalists deported from another
foreign country yes please trend
Information Agency what can you say
about the development of bilateral
relations over Azerbaijan and Russia
in 2018 well I wouldn't I'm not going to
say something about the prospects of the
development of bilateral relations
between the countries let us hope that
relations between Russia and its
partners friends and allies will develop
in a successful way we have big plans in
particular the development of relations
between Russia and Azerbaijan we cherish
hopes hopes of peace stability and the
implementation of old plans we have if
there are no questions see you next week
make rehearsals I'm waiting for the show